your Netflix movie it's called
horse-girl so is it about a horse and a
girl or why is it called that it is
about a girl who used to ride horses and
she no longer really does but she
continues to have a current obsession
with her horse but that I wouldn't say
that's the main that's sort of like
information about her character it's
really about a socially isolated woman
played by me who begins to have a series
of surreal dreams and starts to lose her
grip on reality yeah I'd say so from
that cliff yeah character going No do
you believe in UFOs or aliens well
that's absolutely okay I believe that
anything could exist I don't know well
the universe does seem so big like
unimaginably vast so and also as we were
writing this movie because I co-wrote it
with my friend Jeff baina so thank you
yes time go ahead and take all this off
thanks everyone yeah doing research we
read a lot of message boards about
people being abducted or people who feel
that they've been abducted and actually
there's a lot of through runs through
lines to those stories that we wrote
into the movie well my whole life I mean
when I was in middle school my mom had
this boyfriend who was really into alien
stuff we watched a lot of x-files yeah
that Scully Mulder okay of course I know
them all and he definitely told a story
to me that stuck with me for so long
about his encounter with aliens where he
was driving maybe through New Mexico and
it was just desert and there were lights
behind him II thought it was a big truck
but then it came up went over his car
then he pulled over at his next stop it
was a diner and he was eating a burger
and the Burger Chef had the longest
fingers he'd ever seen that's not real
he made that up to scare you guys I'm
saying it it does sound like he probably
scared me but but my whole life I just
thought it was real so I would say I'm
not into that at all yeah
if you like it way to go yeah so you are
so great and glow and now I hear there's
another season right yes we're doing our
fourth and final season that's exciting
so you have you had such a great time I
hear that like you just had the best
time with all the female it's a female
casting you'd think like that could get
a little like Oh Daisy God it was so
good the cast of 15 women it is the
least dramatic thing I've ever worked on
and it's the greatest job of my life I I
love that we get to do everything on it
you know we get to do dramatic scenes we
get to do really broad comedy we get to
do something that's really physical in
the ring yeah learning how to wrestle
changed the way that I relate to my body
it's been really empowering and it's
just fun it's just really fun I love
everyone Betty Gilpin has become my best
friend I feel like sometimes I think the
only point of the show was to bring her
as a soul mate into my life I think if
that does happen I think that we do go
through different paths and it's just to
meet these people then you go on with
something I I believe that's true yeah
that's so cool though because I think
you should love is you know how to make
animal they balloon animals oh yes
because why because I worked for a
summer as a clown for children's
birthday parties I love it don't worry
so how did that feel about you were like
I'm just gonna start being a clown like
it was right after high school or maybe
in between my junior and senior year and
I had a couple friends from high school
drama who were like oh we got this great
job for the summer being clowns you
should do it it's super easy and fun and
are the offices were actually in Compton
we had a big warehouse where we learned
how to make balloon animals paint faces
and do a few party games with the kids
and we came with like a duffel bag and a
boombox so I would drive to this
building in Compton do my clown makeup I
wore a big yellow afro my clown name was
Sonny and then I would drive all over LA
to all different types parties and tiny
apartments parties in big beautiful
mansions and yeah and I would just come
in by myself put some music on for an
hour to paint their faces make balloon
animals
would make me so nervous because kids
are not the nicest all the time so this
day I think it might have been the bully
training for my career as an actor right
to be fearless yes and to really
entertain a crowd of people who and to
know that no matter how hard you try
you're still going to set to someone
[Laughter]
very impressive for my kids can you
teach me how to make an animal balloon I
want to do this definitely okay okay
[Applause]
okay so the important thing is that
first of all when you blow it up you
always want to leave a little room okay
so you got to fill out the room we're
gonna start at the other load up the air
gets pushed so nice displacement we're
gonna make just like a standard four
legged animal which is a good base zone
cuz then you can always like elongate
the neck it's a giraffe like just
everything it's a poodle yeah so we're
gonna start by making we're gonna twist
the balloon into three circles so you're
gonna do one I'm just afraid it's gonna
be rough it's totally fine and then
you're gonna do and you know hold on to
it okay and then you're gonna do
anything like stay a few times
hold now twist this section oh okay okay
okay and now hold it here not into that
that into are you
okay wait so then he said he take that
[Applause]
okay great
now you got a few more time so you make
a little neck and then you do it again
I just like to encourage okay more than
[Music]
[Applause]
like that and then what no no cuz
they're gonna I don't kill is okay okay
and then the last one okay okay okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's actually terrifying cuz I keep
feeling it's gonna pop him I've had a
lot of balloons I throw a lot pardon my
kids they always pop in my face you know
I'm very proud of this number so I'm
staying right there yeah worked hard for
that I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this